Kaleigh in a previous life before you
were press secretary you work for the
campaign and you made a comment I
believe on Fox in which you said
President Trump will not allow the
coronavirus to come to this country
given what has happened since then
obviously would you like to take that
back well first let me note I was asked
a question on Fox Business about
president's travel restrictions I noted
what was the intent behind those travel
restrictions which is we will not see
the coronavirus come here we will not
see terrorism come here referring to an
earlier set of travel restrictions I
guess I would turn the question back on
the media and ask similar questions does
Vox want to take back that they proclaim
that the coronavirus would not be a
deadly pandemic does the Washington Post
want to take back that they told
Americans to get a grip the flu is
bigger than the coronavirus which is the
Washington Post likewise want to take
back that our brains are causing us to
exaggerate the threats of the
coronavirus does the New York Times want
to take back that fear of the virus may
be spread spreading faster than the
virus itself does NPR want to take back
that the flu was a much bigger threat
than the corona virus and finally once
again the Washington Post would they
like to take back but the government
should not respond aggressively to the
corona virus I'll leave you with those
questions and maybe you'll have some
answers in a few days